okay so eric despite having the white
pieces might be up against it um often
in chess if you come up with someone
against someone with similar styles that
tends to be a kryptonite if you're a
slightly lower rated player okay so
king's pawn opening meanwhile will we
see the spanish will we see the italian
game uh eric he's quite classical in
terms of his opening choices at least
with white um usually he does employ the
spanish opening he's just having a pause
here maybe just putting on the show
as a streamer he loves those facial
expressions and then i'm pretty sure
he'll bring out his bishop but where and
it's the italian game
and uh level narration bringing his
knight out
very interesting invitation to play
knight g5 the most sharp opening yeah
but not actually this opening choice
from the black side shows um that levon
is trying to avoid all the central uh
options what we have seen in the game of
yes panko vs nepalminishi uh here
he goes to play the system with d6 and
the g-pawn move one perhaps one of the
most
aggressive systems in italian in
gigapiano kind of
defenses
so
already exciting so uh h6 move
challenges white yeah it's definitely
not going to lead to positions that eric
can just play purely on pattern
recognition on uh just on autopilot so
already eric's spending a bit of time
and this is one thing actually we
noticed on the tour last season when
eric played he was in time travel very
early on in some of his games and
aronian is going to try and hammer home
that point by playing quickly and okay
white castling as you mentioned the pawn
in the center pushing forward just
solidifying things before black decides
whether to go on the attack immediately
and moment of truth do you think that g
pawn with black is going to say is it
going to push one square or two squares
it's only got one square
g6
safety for now white is preparing to to
play d4 black wants to finish the
development and then to see uh g5 is
leading to huge complications and kind
of memory checkup with the computer
lines uh levon
tries and wants to play some chess first
so g6 is known positions uh blackwood
castle short and then try to to play
knight h5 and kind of king side play
white leads to the central play
i expect the a pawn move a4
development of the knight from b1
so
surprising that eric is thinking
perhaps this is the point
having the reference to his main
repertoire where the bishop b5 has to be
played i think uh all the playing with
rookie one is already slight in accuracy
for white
uh
but uh let's see
nothing very special is happening both
sides trying to develop the pieces um
eric has to remember about his light
squared bishop by the way night night on
a5 all is all the time in the position
so i'm just checking the databases and i
can just see that there's basically two
plans you know white can just keep
things flexible by developing the
the the knight on b1 to d2
or it can actually just uh strike in the
center immediately he can actually play
d4 and check in the database and see
david you've actually played this
variation with the black pieces yeah
it's uh actually this has happened the
latter option you mentioned ivanka and i
tend to play this position as black
either against lower rated players but i
just want to position and i just want to
get a game no opening theory uh or i
play it in blitz just because black's
plans black's moves are quite
uh automatic so um okay we do see level
iranian castle as black now and i don't
think we'll see any trades in the center
yet that would be a very unambitious uh
decision by white just maybe trading and
then trading queens at some point that
would just lead to a very
level position i think we'll see eric
try to maintain the tension if he can
maybe by bringing his night out maybe
just playing an innocent looking pawn
push just maintaining the tension
um yeah we'll find out a lot about eric
hanson's mood on the next couple of
moves whenever you're challenging top
players you would feel really really
uncomfortable to trade all the pieces in
the center like
giving them the lead in the game to say
okay i'm ready for a draw i'm ready for
a draw and please try try to beat me
yeah he has done that maybe this is the
psychological choice to force levon to
play for a win with black
a5 automatic to to grab some some space
advantage on the queen side yeah easy to
play for both
both opponents white is playing in the
center black would potentially deliver
the bishop vrf8 to c5 uh
equality right david yeah just very
equal position and here it's just about
understanding who feels the position
better who puts their pieces on better
squares and yeah let's go back to the
players i'm not i must admit i'm not
happy with eric's decision i think if
the fighting chess index could maybe
understand the psychology of some of
these moves it would not be impressed
even if this game goes on a long time
that wasn't really a fighting decision
by white or not the most fighting
decision um he's not trying to punish
level neronian's opening instead he just
wants a position where it's roughly
balanced and
minimal risk for white that being said
queens are off but everything else is
still on the board pretty much it
started out really nice for lebanoroni
and in the tournament winning two games
but uh
after that uh a couple of losses now uh
is he one of those players who's sort of
uh influenced by this this you know the
fighting format that we that the the
organizers are imposing and you know
taking chances
i think judging from lavon's play in the
previous season yeah i think no he's
absolutely not influenced whatsoever for
him this is normal you know he's decided
to embrace this tricky aggressive style
where he's just playing quickly and
putting the opponent under pressure and
uh
here you know it just happens to suit
him though it's all about fighting chess
one thing that did surprise me i have to
say about levon's play was i would not
have pushed my a pawn uh two squares
forward i was more considered
been a bit cautious and i would have
perhaps pushed it one square forward but
uh having said that
i actually really like what lavone has
done actually retreating the night
getting ready to maneuver it to a better
square and not really caring that his
knight can actually
be traded away for the bishop and his
pawns are going to be doubled
or troubled
as we learned yesterday
although yes although this morning i saw
that there was a new rhyme that someone
had posted on twitter that said double
pawns should never be scorned
[Laughter]
we're going to keep we're going to have
those rhymes coming whole tournament i
love it now i do have an interesting
fact coming in from um chess by the
numbers that we know very well on
twitter and he's also working together
with the champions chester organizers to
get all those interesting stats about
the players and about the games out
there and he is actually saying that uh
coming into this game hansen is around
64 to qualify for knockouts of
honoronion only 40
so it's almost feels like this is a
little bit of a must-win
at least must not lose situation for
levon aronian
then then it explains the choice of the
opening or kind of decision to trade the
queens because uh perhaps eric thinks
let's let's avoid the risk this is the
third game per day a little bit tired
already obviously and let him play and i
will simply control everything cool
yeah that being said
as white if you take negative decisions
if you play for the draw if you try and
control things too much you can backfire
and i don't think white's necessarily
worse or struggling but i like what
levon neronian's doing it feels like
white has wasted a lot of time with the
light squared bishop blacks minor pieces
in the center of the board especially
those three the two knights the bishop
next to it pretty much perfectly placed
and also look at the 11th time
management
yes wow
yeah he simply knows the positions i i
believe he already started at home the
delivery of the night of this the 2d6
already i mean all the way into move 15.
yeah wow
that exact position definitely something
similar he's studied before and
he'll have a great feel he'll try and
put pressure on the clock
psychologically and eric at some point
he'll just have to start playing
objectively on the position not just
worrying about the tournament standings
yes he's doing great so far in the
tournament but uh
well yes the draw would be great with
white as well but
yeah he will have to play some good
moves in order to get that yeah but if
we look at the position uh
a5 pawn goes to a4 f7 pawn goes to f5
what is the white's plan then yeah
exactly sit
sit and wait and hope and pray
[Laughter]
i think that's what eric is asking
himself as well
he's just trying to come up with a plan
because it's not straightforward at all
for white black has those pawn breaks
and actually in these types of positions
it's all about that right you're getting
it's all about pawn breaks who has the
uh who can get the action going and who
can choose when to initiate the action
and right now it's definitely black yeah
white just has to put the pieces on the
best squares and hope that when the
action does finally happen that he will
be ready
it's not so easy to do that though
no it's really not easy to find an
active plan but
i mean the only thing that i could think
of is actually pushing the a pawn two
squares forward but you know that's
making a long-term weakness out of the
pawn on b3 which is totally unsupported
but then
the alternative is just putting all the
pieces on the second row or the third
row and just
doing nothing i agree with you one cause
pawn has to be on a4 just leave the
knight on d2 forever develop the bishop
more or less active to a3 and
keep the pawn structure at least like it
is now because uh otherwise uh there is
uh there is the rule the site uh which
can change can modify the pawn structure
usually having the advantage so because
you have to at least you have to control
this uh pawn structure changes uh the
four uh
levon has a lot of opportunities
advancing on both sides and a4 move at
least stops him from that
yeah you stop black getting any action
on this side of the board this black
pawn is fixed and it's never going to be
really possible to arrange this uh this
pawn push at least not in the near
future and yeah as you mentioned guys
this knight is now fixed on the square
protecting this pawn uh which is eyed up
by the bishop but maybe it can stay
there forever and uh once you do get
your bishop to this square at least you
have some active pieces
um so yeah the more i look at it the
more i think this is
almost forced at this point or at least
strategically it's desirable so yeah
eric i guess he's just wondering what
happens if the pawn pushes if black
takes immediate action in the center and
immediately tries to explode things open
um some i mean now it gets concrete it
looks like a maneuvering battle both
sides just trying to place their pieces
perfectly but black's pieces are already
great so maybe black is ready to
initiate
um those pawn trades to open things up
especially for this bishop on this long
diagonal
and okay he hasn't gone for that pawn
push instead he's brought his bishop to
this square and now
it's now the moment you have any you say
it you said okay well before we could
even come to a decision
the answer is yes
and now black is the one who has the
tension can release it any time i don't
think white ever really wants to push
this pawn forward because now this
bishop is boxed in
and i don't think you're ready yet to
trade maybe you can take this knight
but in general giving up the bishop pair
is risky
and potentially the dark squared bishop
gonna be opened because i believe they
want my take with a pawn and then
potentially to play d5 yeah and somehow
everything is hanging from the both
sides
the herbs i'm missing the c4 but uh i'm
not sure that it's going to exist
yeah dark squares are weak of course
c4 is preventing d5 from the activity of
black from one side but from the
opposite side strategically it's
horrible
and
i i don't like white's position uh
the
this is what exactly david been hoping
for we all
mo okay not all most of the chess
players are superstitious and uh
we believe in chess goddess kaisa and we
say in case you are playing for a draw
at some point you're going to be
punished for that always punishes you
right yeah not always but at least you
you always feel that you can be punished
for this
ah it's psychological kind of
so we'll all yeah well all chess player
have what kaiser is that it
will they always have her you know
lurking on their shoulder whenever they
like
no even if we don't know we do have a
conscience we feel honor bound to play
for the win and on about to take the
correct objective decisions and no
especially with whites if you've got
negativity on your mind something at the
back of
your head does say okay i deserve to get
punished and you make that happen
because it's on your mind at the number
of times i've just needed a draw with
white in the final round and i play for
the draw and i get punished it's it
happens to all of us but it's it's
definitely a phenomenon and is kaiser is
she an actual
i don't know if it's greek or what
mythology she's from is she an actual
chess god or is it something chester has
come came up with
actually you had a question didn't you
david did i yeah
you asked the players
the question about that
no no it was it was uh when with a niche
and tudor and it was like something
happened oh this is true oh what was
that great memory ivanka so just before
the tour finals when anish gary magnus
garcon and christophe duda they were
here in oslo i had a question about
kaiser uh i gave them a quiz basically
and i was asking about the origins i
think it was italian but ah even i can't
remember
the answer
for anyone at home who knows tweet us
okay but she is there it is a god it is
a chess god she does uh exist you know
if we believe then she exists exactly
all right well levon ronin he's uh
finally thinking i guess that's a good
news for uh chess bra eric thompson yeah
he's got plenty of time to think level
neroni and that one thing we did notice
from the tour last season he was playing
instantly most of the time but he would
often pause at critical moments and then
just formulate a plan and then kind of
the pattern would contin continue he
would then speed up again he would kind
of change the
pace of the game just to put his
opponents off and white's last move is
rather non-committal just pushing a pawn
uh not on the side where the action is
really happening and levon maybe he's
just wondering does he continue trying
to open things up or does he just take a
time out and if he does take a time out
how to improve the black pieces they
look pretty great to be honest i'm not
sure exactly how
i think this is the reference to old
petrossan's plan
to get the knight to d5
yeah david has to show this maneuver yes
uh knight h4 g2 e3 d5 yeah so
um
i think uh chess brother find that
knight on f3 is the worst piece in the
position having no potential squares
and he
he wanted to replace the guy to to the
center at least on e3 it's uh it's more
safe of course the knight on d2 gonna be
hanging and some like potentially
hanging in some lines but uh he he must
do something with the with the knight
from f3 especially when you have no no
plan and time time is getting shorter
and shorter yeah often these types of
positions with this type of pawn
structure it's all about the night
maneuvers black's knights look great but
maybe there's no destination for them
next
and meanwhile white's knights they kind
of get in the way of each other and it
would be nice for sure to reroute one of
them and yeah this plan i've seen it
before in action a few times and it's
always kind of impressive when it does
happen but it does take a long long time
and uh as uh as you mentioned there if
the night moves then this guy no longer
protected maybe there'll be some
discovered attacks so that is what eric
is weighing up right now whether he can
get away with it or if he can't go for
this plan yet how to prepare it uh
meanwhile level around pushing this pawn
forward makes me think he's going to
reroute his knight at some point maybe
drop his darts away bishop off uh drop
it back and uh okay eric just using this
king
uh playing this king move he's taking a
square away from the knight that knight
no longer has this square available on
that journey of getting
i'm just i'm just trying to understand
what's what uh what the king g2 means
maybe he
he prefers to to get the knight vr g1 to
e2 somewhere
let's let's try to play with the knight
yeah
or
there is a different strategy that
eric doesn't see any kind of
any kind of plan in the position he also
doesn't see how levon can can improve
the position and he he waits yeah
i think this is just a waiting move to
be honest um i think it was kramnik who
said anytime you put a pawn on g3 you
have to put your king oh well if you
don't have a fiance bishop you have to
put your king behind it on g2
so yeah just a very general move and now
we'll see what levon has up up his
sleeve i have a feeling it might involve
dropping the bishop back at some point
um if not then he might play for this f5
break but it doesn't feel like black is
ready yet to play yeah so actively i
like the bishop retreating immediately
because after all you threatened the
ghost of maybe some tactics along this
diagonal
just bringing your knight out the way
somehow yeah exactly i mean there is
nothing actually concrete here but in
the future it's something that could be
lurking yeah exactly when you're up on
the clock as well it's nice to just hint
at some threats even if you're not
actually immediately
trying to
do anything at least your opponent has
to burn time thinking of the ideas here
on this diagonal
now that
black has a quite far advanced pawn
there as well uh is that going to be an
important piece for levon eventually
yeah i definitely don't think he wants
to trade off this pawn anytime soon
because then the position becomes a bit
easier to handle with white these rooks
just balance each other out so yeah as
you mentioned this this pawn um actually
this is pretty much the only imbalance
in the position right now black is the
one he kind of holds the key he can
decide when to turn it and open the door
for his rook on this file and as long as
white doesn't have the opportunity to
block
here it would just uh actually ruin
white's position this bishop would not
be happy about pushing that ball forward
then this tension always favors black
yeah to answer shortly the because of
this spawn black has an advantage in the
position it brings a lot of pressure to
the white scamp yeah wow
that one small little pawn
well he's actually trying to maximize
the use of that pawner because uh by
moving that knight to the edge of the
board lavon ironian is breaking the
rules here because you know that knight
doesn't don't belong in that square
instead he's trying to reroute it to
this to the square that uh david is
highlighting and maybe that a pawn can
actually push itself one square further
but the computer does not like that move
yeah it's kind of going backwards and
now i think after this exchange okay
black is actually taking with the pawn
if he had taken with a rook white for
sure would have brought his bishop out
you don't want to give your opponent the
bishop pair so now after partying with
one bishop white wants to trade off one
set of bishops but level iranian has
gone for something similar to what
evgeny mentioned earlier just changing
the pawn structure creating a small
imbalance which increases potential
winning chances and uh yeah he wants to
really explode open the pawn structure
for his bishops later in the game so uh
really interesting moment here the
computer really likes white's position
suddenly
i'm struggling to understand why to be
honest it does look quite pleasant for
black especially if he can organize a
pawn break in the center later yeah but
at the moment i see that the bishop on
g7 is out of play knight on a7 is a
little bit too far from everything
happening on board
light squares is under white's control
there is the potential outpost on b5
there is a lot of pressure on b6 spawn
so uh there is a lot of sense in what
eric has done and also there is bishop
c4 opportunity which david mentioned
simply to
uh to get rid of the light squared
bishops and guys uh just while we're on
the topic these double pawns are they
troubled pawns or are they straight
troubled
i was incredibly shocked when i saw eric
take that because it might be viable to
take that pawn now but in the long term
if he doesn't hold on then i think his
position is in tatters and he's trying
to hold on he brings his bishop to this
square where it kind of uh it's anchored
by a pawn but it also protects its own
portland yeah it's all about the light
squares right now can white hold on to
them and wow slow move by level neronian
and
maybe eric simply wants to freeze the
position by playing c4
kind of uh yeah bishop on b5 is a big
pawn since then but there is no single
break afterwards
yeah and
there are a lot of maneuvers uh possible
delivering knight to e3 attacking the
d-pawn so the
uh sorry to say pawns looks ridiculous
all of them
even the bishop
is the big one but
uh
yeah
uh a lot of sense behind because it
freezes the position and uh actually i
feel white is better now yeah it does
look that way the opponent has more
bishops after all and blocked positions
do not favor bishops bishops do not like
those block positions so i think
i would be tempted as well very very
tempted to push this pawn forward and
just freeze everything lock it down
so and that is a good situation for
white even if it looks a little strange
with the pawns in that sort of formation
it looks bizarre but it does favor the
nights long term okay uh because it is
so blocked it looks like white is
playing checkers on the light squares
like it's playing on the dark square so
and there we go it has happened yeah
it's very uh you know it looks like um
you know it's very square
very sharp edges on this chessboard
right now
yeah um
i don't even know how to describe this
pawn structure yeah it's quite a rare
one and
i'm slightly surprised that levon has
rushed into this i mean yes he's still
got a lot of time on his clock but
in terms of the position as well he was
the one who kind of forced this to
happen he was the one who gave up a pawn
not necessarily forced as well and uh
that pawn that we said was the pride and
joy of black's position it has been
captured it has disappeared
but
i mean the thing is though if black does
manage to get rid of the light square
bishop those pawns will be back to being
terribly weak so for me it would be all
about if i were playing with the black
pieces just maneuvering the knight to a
better square because that knight is not
doing a thing so i'm thinking if it can
primarily go to the a7 square maybe to
c6 and maybe jump into the center
yeah but you have to count on the white
side as well yes they they also
delivering e3 and d5 and
just now levon put the rook under some
frets uh from d5 square
and you're a spoilsport
this is the problem with chess there are
two people playing the game
we all see our own pretty patterns but
we have to get our opponents uh what was
the seven deadly sin that was uh that
was egoism where you just focus purely
on your own plans you forget the
opponent or you overestimate your
opponent your position i forget the
opponent's defensive resources so yeah
jonathan rouse in seven deadly sins yeah
i recommend checking it out it will
definitely make you aware of some of the
mistakes definitely on the sale right
now and i yeah i think that is maybe the
the biggest sin the one i make the most
often the the egoism you know you just
see this perfect plan for yourself
and i there's no room in my head for the
other player's plan i just it's human
nature kyle you're not alone even many
top grand masters they focus just on
themselves but
yeah i think once you master that once
you start looking at your opponent's
plans first and stop them before they
even arrive then uh yeah i think that's
the key to making a big leap how does
that work in practice when you guys play
your chess games do you
look at your own plan and always also
sort of before you make your move what
is his plan we try to predict uh first
of all the opponent's ideas yeah is that
what the first thing you do yeah
the this is the rule what does he want
uh as my first coach said try to sniff
around
how does it smell what is that
and you know stuffy chest tournament
halls often sniffing around too much
and uh they then already make your plans
according to what he wants so you have
to cross his ideas and to come to yours
so first look for his plan then make
your genius plan yeah if the opponent
doesn't have a plan or nothing that
looks too dangerous or if you think your
opponent's plan is slow then you can
start focusing on your own ideas and
often it's a race between your
implementing your plans and the
opponent's
uh the opponent's ideas so okay
meanwhile a couple of moves lev on
already pushing a pawn forward and that
has invited eric to bring his knight
into the black half hinting that he
might trade off his knight for the black
light squared bishop and okay that
lightsaber bishop has just stepped back
it's retreated
yeah but it's pretty logical because in
case of capture on d7 at least uh there
are a lot of for
the white coats
or white ones going to be weak
but no nobody would take that bishop so
here
eric offers to to trade on b5 and to
like to improve the pawn structure
yeah i mean i made a sound a few moments
ago and that's just because white knight
is about to enter the most beautiful
square
on the board the d5 square
it's an outpost and black had to prevent
this black had to bring his knight to um
to potentially trade itself off for
weight tonight if it does enter
so yeah it's still all about the light
squares right now all about those white
pawns that we highlighted a moment ago
they look weak but they control so many
squares and
all right but if you're taking a count
the clocks and the board
what would you choose david white or
black on the board i would choose white
every time um
i'd be slightly nervous having
so much less time i mean that's my
normal default setting having less time
than the opponent but still um it does
mean that if you lose control for one
second here white has complete control
but if you lose control then the black
bishops might come to life all your
pawns might start dropping off and
anything can still happen in this game
for sure wow
interesting eric hansen he's having a
fantastic tournament 11 points so far he
is above 50 to qualify for the knockout
stage that's going to be
a huge shock if he does he was one of
the lowest ranked players but he's
playing some fantastic chess
levonironian is in trouble
yep in trouble and i think eric's yeah
that we see three points above him in
the tournament standings and uh a
drawing for eric in a position of
strength now would still be a fine
result uh meanwhile white's knight
is about to retreat possibly i say
possibly because it uh there are options
yeah
just on the previous move uh eric's
squeezed for the critical moment i i
would prefer to think for for a second
if possible to take the pawn on d6 after
bishop h6 even the knight was hanging on
uh on g5 okay so in this position yeah
just pushing this pawn forward defending
the night with what eric chose but brook
takes pawn would have been interesting
yeah there are ideas such as bishop
check maybe though
then i'm blundering because my idea was
the opposite bean in case blake grabs
the knight on g5 uh to to double on d
file okay and to get some some more pawn
but
yeah the the there is about the check
and uh i always remember vasily smith
mislove who said uh all my life long
time scared of their
forks beans and checks
yes yeah and they're very relevant in
this type of position so let's catch up
with the game so white did defend the
night black pushed the pawn forward
attacking the knight and we did
eventually see this trade and i'm
slightly surprised we saw eric rush into
that exchange i would have tried to
delay as long as possible and make black
uh for example if you retreat make black
catcher because now you can at least
protect all your pawns but uh okay eric
does he have something specific in mind
is he gonna jump in
that looks tempting but your knight
might well get trapped on that square
very risky very very rich and it it can
be trapped in one move almost
immediately so you you hit this rook but
once the rook moves um i'm not sure
exactly where then the king will try and
trap this knight so
i don't know what he's thinking about is
he considering this or is i mean it
looks like playing with fire that move
is he just going to retreat his knight
but then the momentum changes to black
side and black can eliminate one of
white's knights and now the pawns we
mention them they're about to start
dropping and once they fall they're
going to be like domino's one will fall
then all the others will fall asleep
especially with one and a half minutes
against nine minutes i think this end
game
doesn't look promising for white
actually it doesn't look holdable uh
something was missed by by eric and of
course i i would choose to to go all in
now to complicate by knight e6 and then
perhaps delivery of other knight to d5
like what david mentioned or in case uh
rook retreats on the c file that like
rook on d7 is pinned maybe there are
some c5 options just uh
to try to do something uh otherwise if
if you stay with one minute to hold the
position objectively like position of
the pawn down
uh
losing
the pawn on c4 a4 it would be um kind of
tough yeah but there's an interesting
approach there because if you do retreat
the knight as he's done and you don't
have so much time you're able to make a
lot of moves
and you can get that 10 second increment
meanwhile if you just dive in with your
knight
to the
very trapped square
if you can't figure your way out
you're busted and basically doesn't
matter for how many moves you're gonna
lose the game
so where chess plays differ right it's
philosophy to chest it's like do you go
for the maximum but fall on your sword
do you take those risks or do you just
go passive and probably lose eventually
anyway and uh just suffer for ages with
a small chance of drawing but
um yeah i mean this position i'm less
pessimistic maybe than evgeny but it's
horrible for white right it's you're on
the defensive and your pawns are about
to fall but all depends on the one trick
so in case uh he's doubling the rook on
d file uh rook d3 then d5 could happen
so and and the fork on e4 yeah that's
the point
so right now white's going on the
counter attack against some of black's
pawns eric's shaking his head look at it
yeah he knows that this the advantage
has gone away and now he's forced the
defensive and he's under a minute on the
clock
um really really tough task ahead of him
and yeah this is why players like level
around there at the top of world chess
for so long because yes they can be
suffering sometimes they can have bad
positions they find their way out of it
quite often and it's hard to keep
control uh for less experienced players
do you think levon will just simply
retreat his knight you know park his
knight on the eighth row
defend both the pawns and then start
utilizing the rooks yeah black's rooks
are going to be the ones doing the
damage so that looks very sensible uh i
okay i think uh one would grab the
central pawn on e4 not scaring of a
pawns and in case of rook b6 just place
the knight on f5 pretty strong that's
nice simply control controlling all the
center and to get the rook behind the a
spawn yeah so but but it's very pleasant
choice when you have eight minutes on
clock your pawn up you can choose this
you can choose that so he chooses
neither in the end there's too many
tempting options so i liked this one by
ivanka just defending this pawn um but i
also liked your suggestion you have any
just taking this guy and then just
parking your night in the square you've
got this poor majority later and white's
pawns are still very weak instead levon
chose a third option um he just brought
his king forward and after rook takes
pawn he pushed in the center and this
involves a trick if white takes now in
the center then black's knight will
recapture attacking this white rook but
also if you're not careful if you put
your rook on a bad square then there
will be a night check a discovered
attack hitting the king and next move
winning the white rook and okay white
has to be really careful where he puts
his rook now
as mentioned and in this position he
brought it the whole way back to defend
its fellow
but after rook takes pawn
it's equal pawns now but this pawn is
probably doom long term
and still some suffering ahead for white
all right another exciting round of
chess for you guys round seven in the
preliminaries out of 15
bars
oh well okay they're actually quite a
lot of the bars are in the middle but
liam lee it's looking good for him
against mom daryl and i did see that the
bar was all the way over to alexander
kustanik's side in her game against desi
panko but now the bar is uh back to
roughly middle and in this game well
it's over to live on aronian side
slightly
yeah
for a second i got very excited there i
thought hang on the rook is a little bit
loose there uh the white rook that is on
the d2 square but uh it's okay it's all
covered okay it does feel like uh okay
he's still got a great position level on
no risk he's better but it does feel
like maybe he could have maximized his
advantage slightly more so and the
moment the maximum he can hope is three
versus four
uh in the position yeah on one on one
side with uh plenty of droish
opportunities theoretical draws
especially when the pawn on h4 like
controlling two pawns of black of course
uh knight adds some extra extra chances
for black in in this order but it's not
not so easy i i believe levon could gain
more
yeah so he's he's still got the
advantage but it could have been more uh
maybe he should have been more and uh
right now eric does have some chances
he's actually created a threat right now
of bringing this rook that has just
moved up to check the black king kick it
away from the defense of black's knight
so i'm expecting the black knight to
move most likely
or you stop this check with your own
brook
and uh still white has this problem of
the lonely aporn alice as we called her
look at the two white rooks they're
forced into passivity on the second rank
just to defend that pawn and levon
meanwhile it's a bit more flexible with
his pieces in this type of position it's
better to have one porn island and if
you look at all blacks pawns here
they're all connected rather than white
who has two porn islands three connected
on one side but then one isolated pawn
on the other flank if the rooks
disappear however it would be the
opposite white would have a pass pawn to
run up the board
oh and there we go well we do know level
neronian is in great shape right
he came second in the first leg of the
grand prix uh and he's going to play
another one so chances are good that
he's going to
get one of those places for the
candidates right yeah
for for lemon through his whole career
it was the problem to play in the
candidates how to play there but not to
get in there exactly so i i i believe
he's in very good position at the moment
and uh he he looks more relaxed also
recently
um yeah i i
i think that uh levon will not miss the
chances to qualify as well as uh not
miss the chance to to do good in
uh championship store
uh this is uh online chess uh all of
them all of the players
accept as kind of training when you can
check your skills preparative for
classical chess but it's uh it's also
very challenging when you're all the
time playing to your rivals and personal
score counts
of course of course
and uh okay well the bar is still over
to lavon's uh side here in great shape
doing very well after making his move to
the u.s
yeah and he does have the option now of
getting greedy and grabbing that white a
pawn but it would mean that the black
knight is offside for a while so uh big
moment for love on iranian is greed good
here guys
would we avoid uh i think in the seventh
deadly chest since book it's called
materialism would you grab that one
i would not resist the temptation yeah
exactly wait wait a few more moves and
see whether you can make some progress
in a different way yeah because uh eric
after all only has like around about 30
seconds on the clock
so uh you can
you can have some fun in the meantime
you can move the black king you can use
one of the black rooks you have options
all depends on the levon's thirds
because uh he has to proceed
finally eric found this rook b2 rook c2
he would simply repeat
the moves now gaining 10 seconds per
move like
partially by prayer move maybe and lemon
has to decide if he would advance the
pawn e4 allowing the knight to jump or
he has to outplay the knight on a2 so
very soon i expect that we would see not
such a huge time gap between the players
but you can play one move though you can
wait with your rook uh i'm thinking of
the a6 rook move it to the b6 square and
then say hey you can't shuffle your
rooks but uh lavonna's chosen are
different he's actually improved his
cane
yep this is the first move that uh
would have come to my mind i think just
to wait just to sit and ask the opponent
what the reply will be
um eric
down to just over 10 seconds now
okay he goes active with one of his
works i would have gone for your move
again he's just moving the rook back and
forth just waiting um but okay it's hard
to do that it's not human nature so just
sit and wait for your fate um instead
he's trying to bring his rook up maybe
swing it across somewhere i'm not sure
exactly where that rook is going
he provokes uh lemon to her to have the
decision because it's rook c8 and now
knight on c3 uh
is unstable now okay so
he also he doesn't want to wait for a
while he he wants to to get some some
play
finally activating the rooks i i don't
know maybe he's hoping to get some
tricks uh like pinning the king pinning
the pawn but uh i i i believe as far as
i know eric he he wants to have some
activity he wants to have some fun on
board ah it's it's not it's not fun just
to stay with two rooks on the second
rank
just to wait and pray it's the heart of
a streamer right you know you've got an
audience so you know you need to do
something to entertain them but at the
same time the rooks are not connected
together they're not working together
and i'm just afraid that maybe if the
black knight centralizes itself
then suddenly rook takes pawn is coming
and it's
not going to be easy
yeah it's not going to be easy and
meanwhile okay level of rooney plays
slightly strange move protecting from
rook state yeah stopping the plan you
mentioned but then he's walked into a
self pin in a way so
maybe if the white rook comes back where
it came from levon will just choose a
different square for his rook he's not
planning to
um
okay
wow to this square and this one is risky
uh it does try to invite black central
pawn to push forward with a double
attack hitting white tonight hitting
white's rook but that would be met by a
knight check
so it's not a blunder his first instinct
was oh god that's
really risky to play it with a few
seconds left on the clock but eric does
have it worked out for now at least but
black is over painted the moment right
yeah he's over pinned but he's played a
flashy move there love on iranian he's
broken the pin but look at all the rooks
they're all staring at each other right
now all four rooks are looking at each
other the problem is you only have one
move as white you can only capture one
of the black rooks and then the other
black fruit will capture one of yours so
and who is this good for the rook trades
it's i think it's good for levon yeah
he's won a pawn in the process so black
is finally a pawn up it's that four
versus three advantage
um that you referenced earlier you have
getting in
it's not going to be easy
to convert this black doesn't have a
past pawn yet and in order to create a
passport you might have to make some
exchanges which would guide the game
towards a draw that being said black is
the one having all the fun now all
depends on the white snite
if
the guy will be finally placed normally
let's say on e3 then there is the hope
if not black knights come and there is
no hope basically yeah so white needs to
activate the night at all costs it
doesn't look great right now but it was
about to try and find a better squad
okay level irony we actually mentioned
this yesterday on the show he played a
great game at the grand prix against
vincent kaima where he met every attack
with a counter-attack and he's just done
the same his rook was attacked from the
white knight he ignored it he brought
his knight to attack the white rook and
we do see the rooks leave the board in a
rather convoluted way but uh now
yeah what do you think objectively guys
should this be a draw with best play
there's not that many pawns remaining
night and games are so hard right yeah i
i think maybe it's a win
especially with this time control with
this time controller but it's not
objective revelation yeah
because i think black is going to win
this game but if white had an hour on
the clock could he save it possibly
i'm not sure
and because uh
it's going to be some really kind of
difficult convoluted reason because
white's kind of past white king's side
pawns are unsupported
okay so
we do see black centralized his knight
and black's king is trying to creep in
from the side also white tonight where
is it going now
it's going to have to go off on an
adventure to the side of the board there
was no other option it was going to go
pawn hunting right onto the eighth row
yeah but now the night might be cut
right by by night e6 so king and knight
might try to
call to be coordinated but then there
there are some tricks like knight b8
knight c6 it's it's it's not that easy
to to to drop the knight on a6 yeah it
looks offside there's no teamwork with
white's pieces here but the white knight
looks like it will survive and
we'll start to create some threats
so levon i'm slightly surprised he's
playing so quickly because if he makes
one slip then white might be right back
in this
and white might be the favorite to make
a draw so
okay i'm expecting that white knight to
try and get back into the game now
i'm expecting it to go to the seventh
row
and uh at least maybe threaten the
to go to the eighth row and start
attacking some pawns at least some
activity yeah after all but uh
eric looks uh more happy now at least
because he has more half a minute
without a single risk to lose on time
that's very important when you're
playing just on the last
increment seconds
yeah meanwhile white centralizes the
king again so black has two options
either you can go and try and trap that
knight but i don't think you'll quite
make it
or you can try and continue the black
king's journey at some point find a good
post for the black knight and then try
and edge your king closer i don't really
see how black is going to make progress
though and maybe you have to go back in
order to go forward
at some point
couple games have finished magnus
carlsen for example winning his game
against towns nieman that means three
out of three possible wins for magnus
carlsen today that means he has made
that comeback after two losses yesterday
great day for the world champion and who
will win this game or will it be a draw
i guess it's looking quite good for
levon
still good but a lot of hard work to be
done in order to win this game and uh
okay he's re-maneuvered his knight and
now he's pushing the pawns
so white has missed an opportunity to
get that white knight back into the game
on the most natural path if you'd gone
to the other square actually the c7
square black would have dropped his
knight back checking and forcing a trade
if the knights come off it's hopeless
for white uh but white's knight is
finding a way round
uh to get back into the action and
yeah i love on ironian though his king
is so far away from his own king from
his own pawns that if the white knight
gets round then those pawns could well
start dropping
i'm not so sure he's going to win this
one anymore
i mean it still looks good i'd still
take black every time but
eric is playing fantastic with
you know
constantly less than a minute on the
clock he's a speed expert yeah he's very
very quick at calculation
and he he delivers the knight like uh it
was kind remarkable for me that he was
waiting with a very bad knight on a6 to
find the right direction it was possible
two directions let's say left and right
like knight b8 and or knight c7 and he
was like
simply
waited for for the solution of black for
for the black's play and now he found
that maneuver d7f8 that coming to the
black spawn on g6
i'm
i'm also not sure that levon is
going to convert this and just
through back reference to to the magnus
uh three out of three today
i i think it makes him special
he can play one day badly but i don't
remember last time when he was playing
two days in a row quite badly so that
that really makes him uh kind of
very special in the world that next day
he's coming stronger whatever happening
something about his mentality always
makes a comeback yeah even suffering
from covid even after some difficult
games nowhere near his best and up
against some strong players yeah he
finds a way and that's what sets
champions apart in all sports actually
they find a way even when they're
playing badly to get the results i
actually think it's because he loves the
game so much
that for him it's just a joy you know he
just can look forward to the next game
and you know devote 100 of his energy
and just is able to forget the past and
maybe also super eager to get back to
the board after a bad day he just wants
to start playing again yeah it's not
like he's off chess again crap
exactly
all right well these two i mean the
fight goes on and the clock is still
ticking so fast for eric hanson but he
keeps making uh good moves yup great
moves by eric hanson he's re-centralized
the white knight just think where that
white knight was just five moves ago
it's back in the center tying down
black's knight to the defense of its own
pawns and now the white king getting
active as well
i think he's definitely going to save
this game now hey um the clock is maybe
still a factor um you could still
blunder in this type of position but
okay i'm expecting 11 aronian to
recentralize the black king king d6
perhaps making a little
a little trick of knight d5 check
sometimes oh yeah yeah now i believe uh
white king has has the puff to to g5 i
actually expected maybe to play king f4
but i i
yeah we we have uh this position is very
nice for white and in a way that uh
preserves almost every move makes the
draw
agreed and white's knight is going to
park itself on a nice outpost i don't
see how black combines getting the black
king or keeping it on an active square
and using his own knight as soon as the
black knight ever moves white tonight
will start attacking some of the black
pawns and remember if all of the pawns
disappear even if the white knight
disappears as well the black knight on
its own will not win the game so black
needs to keep some pawns alive and needs
to somehow win the white knight
there you go
eric is attacking the pawns and now he's
going back using every square on the
board going off to the corner we had a
rhyme about knights in the corner i
quite can't quite remember it but
knights in the corner not normally uh
advisable but that white's knight using
it effectively and
now it looks pretty simple as a draw
black's pawns can never advance without
uh allowing a trade
well this reverses two is always much
simpler yeah yeah the fewer the pawns
the better from the defensive side yeah
definitely but that means levon will
still push and it will just involve
maneuvering his knight trying to find
the optimum square and catching eric
hanson off guard
yeah but i think eric's got his knight
on a great circuit he's just going to
leave his knight
close enough to the black pawns to cause
some disturbance
and uh here white can wait with the king
white can bring his knight back where it
came from
as it there it goes it's getting ready
to go back and attack the black pawns
black's pawns are just fixed on bad
squares unfortunately and level around
shaking his head there
he knows that this game is not
winning anymore objectively
and for the tournament situation as well
for levon that is not good news yeah a
great point actually he's gonna be stuck
on nine points levon after seven rounds
he will be outside top eight for now
he's gonna have to get some winning wins
in to to be able to qualify i think
punishment postponed yeah
[Laughter]
assuming white makes the draw yeah he
wasn't punished for playing so passively
earlier mm-hmm and uh yeah it's not just
that but levon aronian maybe he knows
that eric's going to be a direct
competitor for the
to qualify for the top eight spots now
i'm just judging by how well eric is
playing and
you always want to beat your direct
competitors but
meanwhile no progress being made both
sides are just going to dance around
with their knights black can't create a
past pawn and this should still be a
draw
how long will lev on iranian try do you
think he'll press for another 30 40
moves yes
yeah really then i'll move 49 he will
make a pawn move yeah so remember the
rule is 50 moves without a pawn move or
without a capture is a draw but uh yeah
i would be inclined to just save my
energy right now i love my long games in
general but there's still a couple of
important games left
but is there one important game left
today
i mean it's his only hope that eric
somehow blunders if he's going to be
able to win this game yeah
he's got to hope that eric blunders one
of his pawns or that he allows a night
trade in an
unfavorable fashion i'm wondering how
the position is if the knights disappear
actually exactly and depends on the
position so it also might end as a draw
okay
because black's pawns are just not
positioned in a in a way that they can
break through and create a past pawn so
even if the knights disappear it might
be a draw but levon wants the knights
off that would be his one hope he wants
the knights off and he wants his king on
the right square
that is the key and that must be very
hard to calculate what is the right
square for that king yeah
especially with not much time left
but look at eric's clock meanwhile he
had seconds left earlier he made a move
i think with two or three seconds left
now he's got two and a half minutes
uh that just shows how easy his position
is to play now he's found the perfect
defensive formation
and uh he can just kind of almost
pre-move not quite pre-move but play
instantly and gain 10 seconds of your
time i keep
you know i think back to world
championship match game six magnus carls
and jana pomnyacci
it ended up being an extremely long game
that seemed kind of drawish but somehow
magnus pushed and pushed and pushed and
pushed and he won the game is it
anything like that this game it was more
complicated okay more opportunities here
you can play simply technically by hand
as we usually say not by brain just by
hand
follow your instincts there of course it
was more complicated because uh jan had
to to take the concrete solutions
against the concrete threats okay yeah
and in that game there were still queens
on the board there were still past pawns
running forward
there was a bit material imbalance here
yes black has an extra pawn but
everything else is equal
essentially so there's not enough
dynamism left yeah to really create
threats
one of the things that i kind of always
look at when i'm judging these endings
is i'm always looking at can a side
creator pass pawn and if you look here
it's not really possible it's very very
difficult to create a pass pawn and if
you are going to create passport
involves trades and then the more trades
there is the more possibility there is
that simply the knight can even trade
itself for a pawn
and the black's problem that there is uh
the weakness on g6 and one of the pieces
must always guard g6 square
either knight either king and you can't
coordinate both of them together in the
center or some somehow because one is
taking the defensive uh need
so
uh
yeah i i i don't know what to say more
maybe yeah levon trying to triangulate
but this as far as we know impossible to
triangulate the night yeah
[Laughter]
yeah you can't lose time with knights
that's the one trick uh i think the only
thing to discuss in this position is
whether they'll reach move 100.
uh eric
leaving the board
is that because it's a draw i think
they've repeated this position
three times
there we go it's a result it is a result
it's over